معظم العناوين الرئيسية هذه الأيام هي
حرب وحشية تضخم العنف
والانقسام ، ومن المفهوم بعد ذلك
أزمات الصحة العقلية ، قال ضيفي التالي
إنه لمواجهة كل
ما يمكننا فعله في حياتنا اليومية
، يدعي أن وصفته الطبية يمكن أن تساعد
الأشخاص الذين يعانون من فترة أطول  حياة أفضل
لصحة القلب والأوعية الدموية أبطأ الشيخوخة
قوة إرادة أفضل وقدرة على التحمل المزيد من الطاقة
نوم أفضل أقل اكتئاب وقلق
المزيد من السعادة والوفاء بالإضافة
إلى النجاح الشخصي والمهني
واحصل على كل هذا بدون آثار جانبية ضارة ،
ما الذي انضم إلي الآن للمناقشة هو
الدكتور أنتوني مازاريلي  هو
طبيب في طب الطوارئ ومحامي والرئيس
المشارك والرئيس التنفيذي
لنظام الرعاية الصحية بجامعة كوبر ، وهو
مؤلف مشارك مع ستيفن تريزياك
لكتاب جديد للعقار المعجزة ، سبع
طرق مثبتة علميًا تفيد بأن خدمة
الآخرين
هي أفضل دواء لك دكتور
ماز آي  قرأته لقد أحببته ، فإن كتابك الجديد
يستهدف حقًا هذه
العقيدة الحالية للمساعدة الذاتية  فكر الآن في
اليوجا التي تخبر الناس بالتركيز
على أنفسهم وسعادتهم من
أجل حياة أفضل ولكنك وجدت
أن خدمة الآخرين واللطف في
الواقع يؤثران بشكل إيجابي على
صحتك وحياتك.
دراسة تمت مراجعتها من قبل الأقران والعلم
غامر بأن الخدمة
والاهتمام بالآخرين هو مفتاح لجميع
الفوائد التي ذكرتها للتو ، إنه ليس
رأينا ، إنه ما وجدناه في البيانات
والعلم يتعارض بشكل مباشر مع
النصيحة التي يقولها الكثير من الناس اليوم.  مساعدة
الخبراء على الدفع والتي هي في الأساس جميع
المساعي الفردية لمتابعة
شغفك والتركيز على الرعاية الذاتية ،
ولكن عندما نرفع أعيننا عن
أنفسنا ونحول انتباهنا
لخدمة الآخرين والاهتمام بالآخرين ،
فهو دواء قوي لا يشفينا فقط.
أجسادنا ولكن يحسن حالتنا
العاطفية وكذلك يغير كيف
ينظر إلينا الآخرون
بشكل صحيح أنت تخبرني أن
أمهاتنا كانوا على حق karma kismet ac  في الواقع
تحدث فرقًا وأنت تقول أن البيانات
تدعمها تعطيني مثالًا
جيدًا في الواقع ، لا يُظهر لنا الكون
شيئًا صحيحًا للكارما أو يدفعها للأمام هي
معاملات نتحدث عن
شيء تحويلي يهتم
بأشخاص آخرين لديه خمس آليات
تؤثر من خلالها  تقوم أولاً بتنشيط
مراكز المكافأة في الدماغ كما يظهر
في فحوصات التصوير بالرنين المغناطيسي الوظيفي ، وثانياً
تزيد ما نسميه
النواقل العصبية الأربعة الرائعة
الدوبامين أوكسيتوسين سيروتونين
والإندورفين ثالثًا ، تقوم بضبط
الجهاز العصبي لتنشيط الجهاز
السمبثاوي الذي يستريح بهدوء
فوق الجهاز الودي.  محاربة أو
هروب رابعًا ينظم
التهاب التضخم الجهازي المنتظم الذي يمكن أن يسبب
أمراض القلب والأوعية الدموية والسرطان من بين
أمور أخرى ، والخامس يخفف
من استجابة الجسم للتوتر وهو سبب آخر
لكتلة المرض.
هل هذا
يتطلب من كل منا أن نذهب
للعمل أ  يبدأ مطبخ الحساء
الآن أولًا بداية صغيرة مع من
حولك ، ما عليك سوى اتخاذ قرار
بالنظر إلى الخارج لتقديم المساعدة والرعاية
والتواصل أكثر ، ما هو مقدار ما تحتاج إلى القيام
به لإحداث فرق في دراسات متعددة ،
إنها مائة ساعة في السنة إذا قمت
بـ  الرياضيات التي تعمل في المتوسط ​​60
دقيقة في اليوم في الثانية هي البحث الهادف
عن طرق لمساعدة الآخرين على طرح
الأسئلة الصحيحة لاكتشاف متى يمكنك
إحداث فرق لشخص ما سواء
كان التخلي عن مقعدك في الحافلة
نهجًا لطيفًا مع الزملاء في  العمل
ربما يكون العمل التطوعي أكثر انخراطًا ،
وثالثًا ، تجد الأبحاث الأرضية المشتركة
أننا نفترض افتراضات خاطئة بشكل لا يصدق
حول الأشخاص الذين
نقلل من شأنهم ، ونفترض أن الأسوأ
، وغالبًا ما نقلل من التأثير الذي
يمكن أن نحدثه عليهم ، وجدت دراسة عام 2017 أن
40٪ من الجمهوريين و 40٪
من الديمقراطيين يعرّفون الطرف المعارض
بأنه شر مطلق اتفق 20 من كلا الطرفين
على أن أعضاء الطرف الآخر
يفتقرون إلى السمات التي يجب اعتبارها هي
الإنسان تمامًا  تفوتك الكثير من
الفرص لتسليط الضوء على
الآخرين إذا لم تقم بتوسيع وجهة نظرك حول
من أنت على استعداد للتواصل معه
بما في ذلك الأشخاص الذين يفكرون بشكل مختلف عما تفكر فيه